[Music]
first is the lockdown the unvaccinated
ever justified in this week's cover
piece ross clark looks at the protest
starting across europe because of the
threat of another lockdown
fraser nelson editor of the spectator
joins me now together with dominic
wilkinson a professor of medical ethics
at the university of oxford
fraser ross writes about lockdowns for
the unvaccinated in europe and to start
what is happening on the continent right
now
well the coba situation is getting quite
significantly worse austria has seen the
steepest increases we're now
seeing um hospitals fool yet again very
familiar stories at this time last year
the difference being that we had thought
in the summer that britain was getting
the worst of it and that the europe
continental europe seemed to be
relatively clear
this goes to show that covet keeps
surprising us and now we're getting the
same conversations in the continent
whether to lock down or not but also
whether to have lockdowns of the
unvaccinated this was austria's
innovation a couple of weeks ago and the
political language in the continent is
changing also quite significantly
there's now a phrase which is being
heard in in germany in bavaria and the
czech republic but this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated in other words that the
trouble is being brought um to the
countries by people who are refusing to
get vaccinated
and now this is beginning to collide in
a very interesting and rather alarming
way with existing political divisions in
europe in germany for example the
unvaccinated
disproportionately tend to live in them
east germany and votes for afd the kind
of the far-right populist group and the
afd so you're seeing this kind of
overlap between what we would typically
regard as far-right populist fairly or
unfairly and people who are now
complaining against vaccine mandates and
the overall issue of civil liberties and
that's something that nicolas farrell
looks at in this week's magazine the
paradox of fem parties that can pretty
much genuinely become fascist com
campaigning in the cause of liberty
against the sort of left-leaning
centrists who are i guess against um the
civil liberty argument and more in favor
of lockdowns and compulsory vaccination
so we're seeing very strange dynamics
but as ross argues in his cover piece it
seems to be merging very quickly into a
kind of culture war and it's not just in
the british press that's making this
point and henrik broder has written a
very good piece in divelt today in in
german where he makes the point that the
language now is almost as if you're
talking about the heretics the witches
the deserters the kind of a subset in
society on whom our woes can be blamed
he says that politics gets into a very
dangerous place when the debate goes
down that line and that's what we're
seeing the debate slide into in the
continent
now dominic fraser mentions the fact
that this is almost being referred to as
the pandemic of the unvaccinated in
certain countries and austria's decision
and they're probably the first to have
this idea of a lockdown just for the
unvaccinated do you think that raises a
moral dilemma
well there are a series of moral
dilemmas that we've faced across the
pandemic
broadly speaking one of them that
that we're seeing raising its head again
is is that the balance between
safeguarding well-being and health of
the population and protecting the
liberties of individuals to make
decisions for themselves and to go about
their normal lives
um
there's also a kind of third factor
which is about treating people equally
so we've we've referred to this as a
pandemic trilemma of choices between
freedom
uh health or mortality
uh and equality and you can't have all
of those values you make your choices
and then you get the results
both in terms of
the ethical values that you sacrifice
and of course the the impact on on
population and on excess mortality
and doubling on that do you think that
you it is more morally justifiable to
have uh you know lockdown just for the
unvaccinated if you're thinking about
you know the greater good to say
so in terms of uh lockdowns and
selective lockdown selective lockdowns
are in effect just
an extension of what has been debated
for some time which is the notion of
vaccine passports
and basically that's about treating
people differently based on
their risk of transmission of the virus
and and prior to that that that whether
or not they've had the vaccine
now there's a variety of questions about
that is that is this an effective way of
managing the vaccine is it proportionate
to the risks at stake is it necessary
are there other ways around it though
those three issues effectiveness
proportionality and necessity are key
ethical considerations and working out
whether this is appropriate it's useful
to think about the alternative so
if you're
if you've got a massive spike in cases
as they're seeing in some parts of
europe
and your health system is seriously
under threat
the alternative is to institute a
generalized lockdown as indeed some
european countries
are having to at this point in time or
to say
we're going to spare from that lockdown
those who are at lower risk
of ending up in hospital or of
transmitting the virus
for many the the idea of a selective
lockdown will look more attractive than
bringing the whole community again to a
screaming halt and sending everybody
back to their zoom offices and
and their homes
fraser do you agree with that it's a
more attractive proposition
no i do think the level of social
segregation the vaccine passports and
selective lockdowns proposes is a really
deeply disturbing notion
again we need to look at who's on the
right and the wrong side of this vaccine
divide in britain if you're poor you're
far more likely to be unvaccinated than
if you're rich if you're black you're
something like three or four times more
likely to be vaccinated than if you're
white now it's not entirely clear why
these and divisions are fallen the way
they have done but there's no denying
we've got the data this is exactly what
is happening now do you want to take a
society already quite badly am struck by
social divisions and make these even
worse
and is there does the state ever have
any moral authority to deprive from the
certain section of society for civil
liberties i'm not sure that's the case i
think the argument for lockdowns to be
honest is borderline but if you are
going to um apply them to apply them to
everybody at least is better than
targeting people who you rightly or
wrongly think pose a greater risk
because let's remember that the um the
argument here is taken on the premise
that the unvaccinated
pose a far greater risk for the
vaccinated but that when you look at it
and drill down that evidence is far more
shaky than you than you might think in
ross's cover piece for example he um i'm
just reading it here he talks about this
german study and which um shows that 80
of those refusing to be vaccinated don't
have a problem with vaccination
in general they're just concerned about
the safety
implications of this particular vaccine
is that um is that necessarily a wrong
and indefensible and position
and also when you look at the data for
who passes on infections then it's far
more difficult to say that the
unvaccinated pose a far greater threat
when they're vaccinated because if you
are vaccinated you're far less likely to
get ill yourself you're far less likely
to end up in hospital if you look at the
hospital figures overwhelmingly the icu
units are full of those who didn't get
vaccinated but when it comes to passing
on the virus then the studies show it's
pretty murky that is simply isn't the
case but if you take the vaccine you're
not going to pass it on and if you don't
do the vaccine you do and also let's
remember there's a third category i
think this is quite important that the
third category of people who haven't who
haven't had the vaccine but have had the
virus
now there is a study recently showing
that previous natural immunity is a lot
more reliable than vaccinated immunity
so if somebody has had covetous been in
bed for two weeks with covert or worse
then that person really is i'm very
unlikely to pass it on so why ethically
would you not include them if amongst
the people you're allowed to be given
their liberties with and also the other
ethical dilemma here and i'll be
interested to to hear your thoughts on
this is what say you're going to fire
somebody if you're not taking the
vaccine this is what the british
government has done with care home
workers no jab no job that's been the
rules um now when i asked sasha javed
about this health secretary a few weeks
ago he said that he basically it would
be a concession he doesn't want to make
a concession to those who believe
anti-vaxx propaganda now that's a one
category of people but what about the
category people who do not you
absolutely believe in vaccination but
cannot see what medical advantage you
take from being vaccinated if you're
already naturally immune a vaccine which
let's remember could save a life of
somebody in the third world who hasn't
yet been offered it so that category of
people morally can you really fire them
if you can't argue but they pose a
covert threat or a greater covert threat
than people who haven't had the virus
but have not been already been
vaccinated so those of a is far more
complicated in the real world than the
theoretical exercises are making out and
that's why i think you're seeing
protests in europe right now people just
reject the rather
facile way in which vaccine passports
and lockdowns for the unvaccinated are
being sold
so it so it's useful here to see one
kind of
area of obvious agreement between us
which is about the
the importance of
uh focusing on what's ethically relevant
so in in terms of transmission of the
virus that what's relevant is is an
individual's risk of transmitting the
virus and of course if they have had a
vaccine or if they've
been unfortunate enough to have the
infection and then have recovered they
potentially are at equivalent risk and
ought to be then treated equivalently
either both locked down or are both
allowed to go about their normal lives
so that i think is uh one of the reasons
why
on the continent many of the vaccine
passport schemes and suggestions in
terms of selective lockdowns
have treated those who have the
vaccination and those who've recovered
from covid
similarly
the uk approach in terms of mandatory
covered vaccination for care home staff
or nhs workers hasn't taken that
approach and i and others have
criticized the government i totally
agree that it's not fair
to to remove somebody from their job on
the basis that they
they haven't had a vaccine where they've
got evidence they can there is
reasonable evidence that uh that they've
had an infection and are not at risk of
passing on the virus that they can prove
their antibodies for example that's a
fairly easy way of doing it so
antibodies or they've had a positive pcr
test within within a period of six
months and indeed that's already
recognized in terms of nhs covert pass
so there's already a structure for doing
that does it doesn't seem like there's
any sensible reason why the government
can't couldn't introduce that to their
policy
but in terms of
just stepping back to the this question
of transmission
uh and the the approach in the continent
it's worthwhile recognizing
what's fundamentally
there are two reasons why somebody
should get vaccinated one is for their
own health and their own well-being
and of course when it comes to state
intervention
in somebody's life for their own benefit
that's we understand that that's a
paternalistic intervention and and the
great uh political philosopher john
stuart mill uh has kind of
very clearly encapsulated the notion
that
the only justifiable reason for the
state interfering in an individual's
liberties
is to prevent harm to others harm to the
self is not enough
so
hard to the self for for a individual's
own health is not a good reason for
having a vaccine passport or selective
lockdown harm to others might be now as
you point out the effect on transmission
is not as dramatic as perhaps people had
hoped there is a reduction in
transmission with with vaccination but
it's not as clear as those who are
vaccinated post no risk of vaccination
those who are unvaccinated and not
immune pose a huge risk there's a
difference but it's not as large perhaps
as we might like but there's a different
way in which the unvaccinated pose a
risk to others health and that's through
uh getting sick and consuming scarce
resources over winter so the the nhs is
is already despite the fact that
actually we're not facing the the
enormous spike of cases
of europe is is already kind of
groaning and creaking and and in danger
of falling over that's what to do with
kobe dishes no well that's that's
because of the the resources it's
because of the the the
flow-on effect of covid and the ongoing
kind of uh number of cases that are
affecting our hospitals so there's a
combination of factors
but if you had a further spike of cases
with a a significant number of
individuals who are then becoming
critically ill what you'd then find is
that that would
pose a risk to other people both people
without covid who couldn't then get into
hospital have their operations have
their cancer surgery
all the flow on effects and of course
other people with covid who would be
competing with them for scarce icu
resources
so one of the i think one of the
plausible rationales for a selective
lockdown in europe although
again i i agree it's debatable whether
that's the right
approach on balance but one plausible
basis is to say look if if our hospitals
are at risk of falling over
one way of reducing that avoiding that
is to lock down those who
to prevent them getting sick and then
needing those hospital resources i i
would say there that you need to look at
the science behind this for example how
sure are we but lockdowns really do
serve as this emergency stop which the
theorists imagine that they do if you
look in the british example for example
we have um the the virus was sent into
reverse before lockdowns took place look
at sweden they've had no lockdowns there
and they were twice able to force the
virus into reverse by not resorting to
lockdown not depriving anybody of their
civil liberty so again the arguments
which are pretty sweeping government
powers saying to say you're not allowed
to go to work you're not allowed to go
to the pub you're not allowed to leave
your life you're not allowed to go see
your family
if this is not on a strong scientific
basis then there's really no moral
argument for this at all so right now i
think we're skipping the really
important part which is does the logic
actually work and right now i'm afraid
to say we've had 18 months of lockdowns
very mixed evidence as to whether they
are effective in sweden a demonstration
of how liberal liberal society can keep
its values while fighting back the virus
and overall very important questions
which many of those in the streets are
raising in protests right now
and so i think there are really
important questions again here about the
the effectiveness of different
interventions and then the
proportionality relative to the benefit
uh i i think i interpret the evidence
quite differently to you that there's
very clear evidence that those countries
that have chosen to lock down have had
as a result a very significantly fewer
overall deaths so sweden has had lower
deaths than some other countries but
it's had very substantially more excess
deaths than its immediate neighbors
neighbors with very similar populations
and and otherwise very very different
urbanization levels so that old i mean
sweden's more urbanized than britain so
we can't really make that comparison so
the uk has had dramatically more exist
mortality than a number of again
relative comparative countries on the
continent and we looked down more than
anybody pretty much last year well no
i mean our lockdowns were by and large
instituted later less stringently than
than a whole series of other countries
they lasted a lot longer britain is the
case study i'm afraid to say for those
who question the advocacy of lockdowns
in keeping the the death rate down
either amongst those recovered and
unfortunately amongst the under 65s our
death rate is really quite high by
european standards that implies that the
side effects of lockdown might be
greater than we're looking at so again i
really think we need to be very clear
about the science before we're talking
about depriving anybody of their basic
liberty i mean again so there's
scientific questions important important
questions and then there's ethical
questions so in terms of the science
it's important to look at whether where
the lockdown work whether they cause
more harm than good overall in terms of
how community think that science would
need to be but i'm really how clear do
you think how sure would we need to be
about this science before we issue
lockdowns and deprive people of civil
liberty on that basis
well i mean one of the challenges of
course in a pandemic is that you have to
make decisions when the evidence is
imperfect and there's uncertainty
one of the interesting questions
has been not simply about whether to
lock down but how much to lock down and
when to lock down of course in the uk
we've chosen to relax lock down earlier
and get anticipating that that would get
a surge in cases
before the winter other countries have
made different choices now perhaps
paying the price for that with now a
surge of cases that coincides with the
winter
and
you have to make decisions in the face
of uncertainty
i don't think it's
we have the luxury of waiting until
there's cast iron evidence i think we
have in the uk made a series of mistakes
uh by waiting to make decisions in the
past at the moment i don't think there
is a pressure on on the uk to to make
decisions acutely to lock down or to
selectively lock down again though that
could change
and partly because the key factor which
is about our health system
being under significant threat is we
have very little room to move because of
the nature of our health system and its
chronic shortage of resources
thanks fraser and dominic
[Music]
you